are we ready to read pillow all right
let's go
cracker now this is weird thread that's
going around with all these protests so
basically what people are saying is that
the website real quick real quick let me
just preface I swear to you I stopped
listening as soon as he started talking
about here's the thing right so here's
the thing all these protests popped off
at the same time mm-hmm
right around the same time right you had
one happened in Minnesota what happened
in Virginia what happened in
Pennsylvania Michigan what happened in
Michigan yeah and I think Florida
whatever like that right so it just so
happened that all these protests and the
protests are against the
shelter-in-place
they pop off in these different states
now information some guy researches on
reddit he finds out that the websites
for all these protests right mark yeah
so the websites for all these protests
what happened they were all registered
at like within five minutes of each
other to like one person in Florida so
if you go by how the websites were
registered one might believe that these
were not unique acts by individual
people in these states but rather a
single actor or a single group that is
manipulating people into thinking that
they should protests is that right
absolutely believe this 1% no we're
gonna go further now that's where you're
gonna lose what are they saying
I said I believe you then you're like
you only said it like just what I'm
about to lose you know no we're gonna go
farther so so here's but here's the
thing that's interesting who is the
group that's doing it right the only
reason we didn't do like a longer piece
about this cuz we don't know who the
group is doing it right now it looks as
if mark so there's like all like these
other like different causal connected
points so like all the Facebook groups
are the same descriptions like they were
all started at the same time all that
[ __ ] but there was one like loose
connection to like
Betsy DeVos what did you say causal
connections that she sounded beautiful
yes you with poetic give me my dick day
that's how you got them eyes so but yeah
basically just like so all the Facebook
groups that represent these things that
should be independent you all have the
same descriptions so all the group's pop
up at the same time right and there's
this loose connection back to Davos
right it could be loose who knows if
it's Davos the Devoe's thing is really
loose all right so let's throw out the
devotes we just know all these things
pop up at the exact same time they're
registered to the same group or person
right and they're all it's happening to
like local gun communities also right so
they're going after the right-wing side
there so you should protect your rights
to leave the house if you want protect
your freedom yeah so all these protests
pop up around the country and then Trump
retweets the people protesting right
right so he sees all the protest and
he's like y'all liberate Michigan
liberate all these places now the easy
connection is Trump has his people go
tell these people to go leave their
house because he wants to get the
economy going right he's like we need to
get the economy going again I can't
force it open the governors need to do
it right so what we'll do is have the
people start to protest and then maybe
the governors will acquiesce like we saw
what happen in Florida and we saw it
happened in Virginia right and he'll go
after his base in these places that will
really do it that's the easiest way now
you had a point beyond that I believe
he's done it once before Trump
we've already knows he paid people to
come to his first rallies paid actors
interesting and then he says outlandish
[ __ ] and then he gets more media
coverage and more media coverage and
then everybody's retweeting it because
how can you say these things happen you
say these things but he's reaching
certain people who were kind of maybe
would [ __ ] with Trump and now they have
access to him where they never did
before and they're like oh actually now
that I'm seeing these messages bombarded
over and over again on CNN I kind of
agree with this guy
honestly this guy like my career
pay my friends to come to my shows
eventually the messaging is good say
some outlandish [ __ ] I really like it
all of a sudden these cells are packed
you just gonna bring her inauguration
yeah but so here's the thing
maybe it's Trump and it makes the most
sense or maybe it's another group that
wants America to be shut down for longer
because they want people out there
protesting eventually getting the
coronavirus getting into the hospitals
more people die American economy gets
shut down for a longer period of time
and manipulating Trump into retweeting I
the only reason I'm like I can't get
behind this and spread the news acting
as if I know what's going on is cuz I
don't want to be a [ __ ] shelf or
China or some other country that's
trying to take America down right now
now I think a CNN or one of these folks
would just jump at the opportunity
because they gets a knock drunkenness
Trump and his supporters last thing I'm
gonna do is what China wants
[Applause]